hey guys welcome to ask IJ now I'm
extremely excited for two reasons number
one I am almost to a million subscribers
so if you're not already subscribed
click right here let's make this happen
and second reason I'm so excited is this
is by far one of the best user submitted
ask IJ intros I've ever seen everybody's
question time now it's time to ask
Justine anything just say hey you can
ask IJ
hey you can ask IJ
thank you all adults here on YouTube for
creating that awesome song you're
amazing and now let's continue on with
ask IJ questions police a the question
kamila wants to know what my favorite
font is my favorite font is Helvetica
and then second to that is a font called
cheeseburger 1/3 - that is a font called
chickens which actually happens to be
the font that Twitter uses for the logo
crystal wants to know how I ended up
loving the Steelers Fraulein from its
Berg so obviously I have to be a
Steelers fan because if you live in
Pittsburgh in you're not a Steelers fan
you will be murdered basically someone
will kill you
ELISA wants to know if the room that I
film in is all white with no furniture
actually no the room that I throw in has
a lot of furniture in it and I'm going
to do a little 360 pan of where I'm
filming at right now so you can see it
looks like I'm in a white room but I'm
not
okay so now I'll show you what the setup
looks from my perspective right in front
of me I have my camera and there's a
really big light and here's my laptop
where he wants to know if I could live
in space and I could choose a planet to
live on which planet would I live on
obviously I would live on Pluto because
when they drop polluted was a planet I
felt that I was directly impacted Pluto
is my favorite planet and you know what
I don't care what anyone says
gluto is blanket me Nina wants to know
if I see myself as a parent in the
future I can't even take care of myself
so I'm pretty sure taking care of a
small human being not a good idea baby
the question Conor that would be a USB
plug to charge your iPhone or your iPad
or iPod pretty sure you know what that
is
I think you're just trying to be funny
funny funny Conor yeah why is that
peacock in the parking lot Laura wants
to know if I had any jobs as a teenager
I actually was super lucky because even
when I was very young I was really into
computers so I was building websites a
very young age I never actually worked a
traditional type of job I was still
doing freelance and design when I was
really young so yeah that was my job
YouTube question do I play call of duty
on ps3 or xbox Xbox do I like black ops
or modern warfare better I only played a
little bit of modern warfare 2 so I'm
gonna have to say black ops is my
favorite but maybe one of these days
I'll go back to modern warfare and then
I can actually answer this question a
little bit more fair hmm
Miley Cyrus or Taylor Swift I guess if I
have to choose between the two
yeah yeah that's a really hard decision
I don't want to answer that question
what is my favorite NFL team well
considering I'm from Pittsburgh I am a
Steelers fan and let me tell you what
this right here is the sweetest ELA
Jersey you will ever see in your entire
life
yeah that's right not just to New Jersey
oh dear i J
can you lick your elbow it's Rita
question I feel like you guys are always
constantly asking me about this white
wall okay I'm glad that I could finally
answer it for you
trogdor a thought that I lived in New
York it wasn't actually a question it
was more of a statement no I do not live
in New York I've never lived in New York
I live in Pittsburgh 47 love gaga 91
wants to know about my family's middle
names it's very strange because no one
in my family has another layer not me
not my sister sister's mom or dad none
no middle names
does anyone else that have a middle name
I'm pretty sure I've asked you this
before but I just like to ask again
because it's very rare rare occurrence
as for the oldest youngest of my
siblings I'm the oldest
Breanna's the middle and Jenna's the
youngest and Jenna's the only one on
YouTube youtube.com slash it's me Jenna
eight you're welcome Jen up for the
shadow thanks so much for watching this
episode of ask IJ be sure to subscribe
so that you'll know when I launch new
videos and check out all of my other
YouTube channels because I post on those
ones as well don't forget you can ask me
questions here on YouTube you can add
video responses you can ask me questions
on Facebook on Twitter on dailybooth and
yeah I guess that's really the only
place to take questions from I wish to
you guys in the next episode